[موسيقى]
نحن جميعًا نحب طيور البطريق ، حيث يتشابه
الأشخاص مع طيور البطريق
التي يتعرفون عليها معهم لأنهم
يتنقلون للعثور على الطعام
بسبب إخلاصهم لشركائهم
لأن الطريقة التي يتجولون بها في بعض
الأشياء الأخرى يرتدونها جيدًا
ولكن الحقيقة هي أننا جميعًا نمتلك  اتصال
مع طيور البطريق ،
اسمي بابلو جارسيا أورويل ، أنا عالم
أحياء وأنا أيضًا باحث ومدافع عن حماية البطريق ،
أنا مؤسس ورئيس
مجتمع البطريق العالمي ،
أحد الأشياء المهمة في
طيور البطريق هو أن أكثر
من نصف الـ 18 طيور البطريق  تعتبر الأنواع
مهددة في المحيط فهي
تتأثر بتغير المناخ
أيضًا بالتلوث البحري وسوء إدارة مصايد الأسماك ،
لكن طيور البطريق تحتاج إلى الذهاب إلى الأرض
لبناء عش ورعاية
خدودها حتى تتعرض أيضًا
للتهديدات على الأرض
بما في ذلك الإنسان  الاضطراب
وإدخال مفترسات غير مألوفة
[موسيقى
] قررت إنشاء مجتمع البطريق العالمي
من أجل استخدام العلم المتاح  o
توجيه
إجراءات الحفظ وأيضًا لإشراك باحثين آخرين
في هذه المهمة ، لذلك مع مجتمع الدفع العالمي
لدينا طيور البطريق التي تجري أبحاثًا مثل
العثور على أدلة ومعلومات
حول كيفية مساعدتهم في حماية الموائل بشكل أفضل
وإنشاء مناطق محمية بحرية وأيضًا
تطوير خطط إدارة للمستعمرات
التي
منفتحون على الزيارات ،
لقد تمكنا من حماية 32 مليون
فدان من موطن طيور البطريق ليس فقط
في المحيط ولكن
أيضًا على اليابسة ، لقد استفدنا من أفعالنا
2.4 مليون بطريق وأخذنا ما
يقرب من 7000 طفل من البلدان النامية
لزيارة المناطق المجاورة  مستعمرات البطريق
التي لم يتمكنوا من زيارتها أبدًا ،
لذلك قمنا بعمل وتأثير
على تلك
المجتمعات وربط الناس والأطفال
والمجتمعات بالطبيعة ،
يتمتع الناس بعلاقة عاطفية طبيعية
مع طيور البطريق ،
لذلك من خلال طيور البطريق يمكننا التحدث عن
العديد من الأشياء الأخرى و  تنفيذ
الحلول التي من شأنها أن تفيد
البيئات الكبيرة والعديد من الأنواع
أنا رقيقة  ك الأجيال الشابة
أكثر تثقيفًا حول البيئة
مقارنة بجيلي ، أعني عندما كنت
في العاشرة من عمري لم تكن
البيئة مشكلة
ولم يخبرنا أحد
بالمشكلات التي نتسبب فيها ،
فأنت لست بحاجة إلى أن تصبح عالم أحياء.
يمكن أن تكون مهندسًا ، يمكنك أن تكون خبيرًا
اقتصاديًا ،
فكل شخص له دور بغض النظر عما
تفعله بغض النظر عن المكان الذي تعيش فيه
في نهاية اليوم ، فنحن نعمل على تغيير
موقف وسلوك الناس لا يمكننا
تغيير سلوك
الحيوانات أو بيئتنا  لذلك عندما
نعمل مع الأشخاص
ونصل إلى هذا الهدف ونرى أنهم
يشاركون حقًا وأنهم يطورون
هذا الشعور
بالملكية ويريدون حماية
الحياة البرية ، فهذا
هو اليوم الذي نقول فيه أن المهمة
(الموسيقى) جيدة